okay we're taking live calls earlier
this week because of the fourth of July
holiday that is upcoming at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
let's go let's see we've got so many
people holding who want to get on today
let's start with our caller from the
three-30 area code
who's calling today from three three
zero this is Jared hey Jared what's
going David uh yeah I'm from Youngstown
Ohio I just wanted to know your opinion
on what regular people could do to deal
with this issue of like child
concentration camps and concentration
camps generally and what even should be
progressives with the correct policy
going forward on this because it's not
enough to just go back to like Obama or
a policy of keeping families together in
these privately run concentration camps
we have to be obviously something more
like yours on that yeah this entire
situation has been sort of held hostage
by creeping normalization as I like to
say and I when I did a segment last week
saying let's debate whether kids in
cages deserve soap or not if 20 years
ago you go directly to let's cage kids
at places like these and we just have to
figure out whether they deserve soap
that's too crazy too quickly and the way
that you get us to that point is by 20
years of slowly normalizing normal line
it normalizing normalizing there's no
question that the D human dehumanization
the dehumanizing rhetoric from the right
when it comes to immigrants and the the
use of the term illegals and so on has
contributed to this so you're correctly
pointing out that just pushing the ball
a little bit forward on marginally
improving the conditions at these camps
is simply not enough and unfortunately
it's going to take more than like one
election cycle to fix this number one
obviously it's not just the president
but it's holding all of our elected
officials accountable for what's going
on because they do have power to
influence what what the law is and what
protocol is but even going beyond that
the entire narrative around immigrants
including stories of they take our jobs
they are dangerous criminal all of it it
all has to be undone and unfortunately
it's like decades of stuff and
so I don't know exactly how we start
doing it and I'm not super optimistic
that it can happen quickly okay thank
you so much um I know that like I live
in Youngstown Ohio and it's hard to get
information on this stuff I just found
out a couple weeks ago that like we are
the city that holds the most people and
ice detention for the state and I don't
even know like exactly where that is
that's interesting - be nice be able to
find out more information on these
things yeah I just wanted to like got
out at Tim Ryan for not doing enough on
this because he's running for president
right now and he is our congressman and
I haven't heard anything from him you
know I haven't followed his campaign
that closely but I also have not heard
that I've heard him talk a lot about
manufacturing in Youngstown Ohio but not
about migrant detention or anything like
that so I think you're totally right
about that thank you David
alright appreciate the phone call thank
you very much great to hear from you